[Music]
hey what's better than one bad ending
per season how about two hs double
feature was so anticlimactic even my
girlfriend got blue balls just kidding i
don't have a girlfriend stephanie please
answer my calls now i debated how to do
this video because i have a lot to say
so i'm gonna do my traditional breakdown
add some commentary and we'll likely do
a separate video unleashing my full rage
but to red tide you over we still have
this last episode so wipe your tears
click that like and subscribe button and
we'll get through this together it's
president nixon not really enjoying the
increasing protests against the vietnam
war it's 1972 and the war is already
seven years in and as we learn from
valiant thor the war is all a ruse to
distract the american people from all
the abductions that have been happening
if you recall back to episode 7 the
aliens were wanting 5 000 abductions per
year nixon hears the bad news that the
first functioning hybrid won't be ready
until
and in order to keep the american people
oblivious to the alien presence a whole
menu of distractions have been prepared
it's implied that things like 911 the
war in iraq and other such major events
were orchestrated by the aliens in order
to distract the american people we also
meet henry kissinger nixon's secretary
of state who happens to be an alien
reptile yep in the very last episode
they decide to throw in this other alien
race who is on earth for some reason and
this totally made me think of the 1983
miniseries v in which reptile aliens
disguised as humans take over the earth
i don't know
three years earlier former president ike
eisenhower is on his deathbed lamenting
the deal he made with the aliens he also
knows the presence of this second alien
species because it turns out one of the
humans thor abducted was one of these
reptilian creatures and it's never
really mentioned how ike knows about
this mamie on the other hand can't seem
to stop thinking about ed day evacuation
day not erectile dysfunction day like
she says it's the day when british
troops evacuated boston during the
american revolutionary war thor arrives
and tells eisenhower that he need not
die he could be taken to area 51 where
the alien tech could keep him alive this
is why we see calico who is abducted in
the 60s hasn't aged a day ike tells thor
and mamie that they deserve each other
which is a slight jab at them
considering they made sweet passionate
robot love a few episodes ago mamie
doesn't want to die like her husband nor
does she want nixon blabbing about the
alien presence so mamie becomes
[ __ ] the secret informant who
leaked to journalist bob woodward that
nixon was wiretapping the offices of the
democratic national committee in the
show nixon had asked gordon liddy to
wiretap it believing it was the office
of valiant thor in an attempt to expose
the alien presence and to make sure
nixon no longer is a problem they have
him abducted and anal probed until he
resigns in 1979 maybe is brought to area
51 to live out the rest of her life
which i guess is eternity i don't really
know they never mention exactly how long
they can prolong life we hear on the
radio that mimi supposedly died of heart
failure calico and mamie instantly
become best friends and we fast forward
to present day right after the deadly
events of episode 9 in which cow was
sucked to death by his alien baby i
don't know about you but getting sucked
to death doesn't seem that bad a special
task force has been brought in to
investigate and when they come across
the dead alien body theta remarks that
she hasn't seen a hybrid anomaly like
this in at least two cycles it is
somehow regressed but it's never brought
up why kendall and jaime end up finding
their friends cal and troy dead in the
moon landing room and you'd think this
room which contains super top secret
information would at least have a lock
on it or something theta uses her jedi
mind powers to knock out the two who
then wake up ready to give birth the
last hybrid to be born there was the
closest they've come to perfection and
theta thinks one of their babies could
be that perfect hybrid thor mentioned
some 50 years earlier jaime's baby isn't
quite up to snuff and both she and the
baby are killed kendall on the other
hand delivers the perfect specimen the
baby is quickly whisked away and
kendall's head severed off only to be
replaced by this giant metal sphere
they'll keep using her body over and
over again as a vessel for producing
these hybrids later on theta will
explain how kendall will go on to
deliver a new baby once every hour with
the news that the aliens have produced a
perfect specimen reaching mimi she asks
thor what's next the plan is to
completely populate the world with these
hybrids while simultaneously eliminating
the human race mimi of course will be
spared and along with her husband ike
will be revered as heroes among the
aliens for ushering in this new world
order thor and the aliens justify their
takeover by telling mimi that humanity
has destroyed the planet he uses a rose
garden analogy that the planet is like a
rose garden and we're the gardener
that's killing all the roses mamie tells
him she knows about the other reptilian
species hiding on earth but as we see
thor and reptile kissinger in this scene
they've already made an agreement to
live together in peace these reptiles
have quote qualities in tech that could
prove useful to them mimi doesn't really
like this plan and asked to see this
hybrid she was so integral in helping
create she wants theta to join her and
calico in killing both the baby and
kendall's body to set back the aliens
and i'm not sure why she thinks theta
would join her this woman has spent the
last 60 plus years trying to create this
hybrid i don't think she's gonna have a
change of heart now i mean the woman
literally kills babies for a living in
fact it seems as though theta leads mimi
on into believing she's on her side
because just as mimi is about to kill
the hybrid theta stops her theta tells
mimi that the greatest shame is the
human part of her and that she won't
help humanity a humanity who has
destroyed this planet with these hybrids
at the helm they can restore balance
theta explodes mimi's head just like
possessed maria did a few episodes ago
and calico is spared so that she can
become a sort of mother nanny to the
future hybrids it makes sense since
calico has given birth to dozens of
children over the years all of whom were
killed and she never got to raise and
the season ends with a new perfect
specimen delivered from kendall's body i
hated this ending on so many levels i
guess the first thing i'd say is that it
was utterly anti-climactic part of this
feeling stems from the fact i really
didn't care about any of the characters
the writers made the conscious decision
to introduce characters like cal kendall
troy and jaime as entitled bratz which
made me instantly hate them since the
beginning of episode 7. mamie is only
concerned about her stupid holidays and
calico has resigned herself to a life of
breeding at this point i really didn't
care if the aliens took over the second
overall criticism of the season is that
there was little to no connection
between the two parts of double feature
nor to the ahs franchise as a whole now
if the creators came out and said look
these are two completely separate
seasons within a season i'd be able to
manage my expectations
but the marketing for this season
heavily played up this idea that the
aliens and pale ones are somehow
connected but arguably my biggest
criticism is the unrealized potential
this season had the first five episodes
of red tide i thought was some of the
best ahs ever written red tide could
have easily been the whole season and
there was so much there that could have
been explored they were in provincetown
where the mayflower landed and they
never had a flashback to that time
period what was the backstory behind the
chemist what happened to the townsfolk
who willingly kept the murders in their
town under wraps to keep up tourism
should i even bring up lyme disease it
just seemed like every bad person in the
season got away with it with little to
no repercussions and look i don't mind a
bad person getting away with something
there are tons of anti-hero movies and
shows out there i at least need to be
invested in what they're doing so those
are my really brief macro notes and if i
have time i hope to come out with a huge
dissection of all the plot holes and
[ __ ] that didn't make sense throughout
the entire season you'll want to stick
around for that dumpster fire thanks for
watching everyone be sure to like and
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much